what do you think uh is the role of
emotion in the human mind
in The Human Condition because you've uh
we've talked several times in different
ways that emotion matters and it's a big
part of Who We Are
but
why is it there why is it useful what's
good about it it
almost said it's almost like a negative
thing that we just have to live with
but why is it also maybe a beautiful
thing yeah well I think he said what's
the role of emotion I think emotion is
the king if we want to use that analogy
it's the CEO if you want to use that
analogy right emotion rules rules all
we're taught that we're logical
creatures but we have innumerable pieces
of data even over the course of just a
day let alone a human experience to tell
us that is not the truth is it ever
logical to to run into a burning
building
no right I mean I'm just never going to
tell when to do that okay someone you
love is in the building the person's
already sprinted halfway to the building
right emotion rules us and so and so the
thought
a thought is some of that is
evolutionary right that strong negative
emotion stays with us very very
profoundly right so example I'll give is
if we're hunter-gatherers and like I
find a new berry and it tastes good and
it seems nutritious and then and it is
right everybody I think it's fine it'd
be good to remember that right but if I
find a new berry and it tastes good and
it seems nutritious and we both eat it
and almost die of sickness we better
remember that right so that so so the
Primacy of emotion is in us for for
reasons that are about survival that the
emotion of it's my child in that
building or my loved one is why I don't
give a damn about logic and run into the
building right the emotion of I thought
that was good and I got really sick and
I better never forget it is also about
survival and the same applies to humans
if if we're from different tribes back
then and in my tribe when you put your
hand out it's a greeting in your tribe
if I if someone puts their hand out it
means hey I'm going to attack you and
take your stuff
but then I put my hand out and you slug
me right then it's like I better
remember that right but you see how that
can lead into you know our our the
constructs around that I say oh people
in your tribe are violent right they're
right we start then to make stories
around that but the Primacy of emotion
whether it's berries or it's humans who
might threaten us or it's humans we love
I I think it's it's hard to to even look
at that anthropological psychological
literature to look at what's out there
and I think the face validity not to
that that's part of survival right it's
part of survival it's so cool that you
get also things like love which are not
often rational or grounded in logic and
so on if you if you look like sort of
from a transactional perspective
a lot of times falling in love or
whether it's with friends or uh
friendship or romantic love it doesn't
really make sense I'm still don't I'm
not I'm still not sure what the hell it
is because it's like I mean it uh it's
the thing that it's one of the things or
love for your kids when they're born
right like that love the the the the the
the parental love
um
what is that that's so cool that we get
to have like if you're looking for the
in the menu of items they give life
meaning that seems like a pretty good
one yeah so my response you said that
Gives Life Meaning my response initially
was going to be it's the meaning of life
right because saying okay emotion is
about survival that's one part right
that's and it's a very important part
right if we don't survive then then
we're not there to have emotions right
so yes it's about survival but as
important as that is that's the small
part of it right I think it is about the
meaning of life because it's about the
Beyond self and I think it relates back
to what we talked we're talking about
the very beginning and the sort of
levels of emergence right and when we
feel love we feel happiness because that
person feels happiness right there's
something that's so generative so
creative about that like we we want to
bring order to things and we we you know
happiness is consistent with Simplicity
right if we're healthy there's nothing
negative to say about our health right
if we have health problems there's a lot
to say right and it's it's emotion that
pushes us towards the the goodness that
I think makes all the meaning for us I
mean it's interesting I actually I was
wondering your your thoughts about this
as a scientist right because we we
accept it by and large that we have free
will right we the only way of free will
but then we get upset that there's not
Justice right so but how is it like if
we have free will I could act in an
unjust way and then you're surprised or
you know Vice like why right we we have
these thoughts because I think because
we're we're rooted we want logic to rule
like there's a way in which I can
understand logic I can manage it I can
manipulate it we sort of want it to be
that way so then we we glorify logic and
then we misapply it like ideas like oh I
know we have free will but I'm now you
know shaking my fist at the heavens
because there's no justice right and I
think maybe what we're looking for is we
should go back and look at the Givens
like why is there there's only goodness
if there's Justice I mean that doesn't
make I I think the goodness why is the
goodness have to be tied to that right
maybe it goes back to the counter
entropy and the fact that when there is
something there is not nothing right and
where there is something there can be
awareness there can be goodness there
can be compassion right is it that that
that what's really going on is not about
Justice yes we have free will but it's
that goodness creating Shoring up making
better that is
the meaning that is the good right and
that the evil is the destruction as
evidenced by the fact that it's over
determined probably a million times that
we're in this Addy current of counter
entropy and we could destroy that quite
readily right and and then we're
nothingness like like everything else
that we know of that's not us that
doesn't have the ability to do something
that's creative or constructive I mean I
think that that's
the answer and I think that our science
really tells us that that's the answer
and I think it beckons us with ideas
like we know that things happen outside
of space and time right I mean they're
physics experiments right like we know
this from the science of it yet we don't
stop and look and say wait is that the
magic of the idea Einstein said God
doesn't play dice with the Universe I
think okay maybe
God doesn't play dice with the universe
that Quantum and determinacy and all of
that is not just a flip of the coin so
to speak but maybe it's in that
indeterminacy that we're given the
opportunity to assert ourselves right to
make something one way or another you
know maybe it's not God playing dice
with the universe but it's God loading
the dice in our favor if we'll only
listen to truth the truth that being
destructive doesn't help pursue anything
even in the person who thinks it will
for themselves and that creativity and
generativeness and kindness and
compassion like this doesn't that seem
sort of analogous to the Eddie current
of counter entropy that has us here in
the first place and I think that's where
I I pin meaning and that meaning then
going back to the initial question right
is is generated in us through emotion
through what we feel that lead us to
feel something that is mysterious I
don't know why I feel it yeah in some
sense the motion is the kind of the fuel
of that creative imperative we have but
if you step back and look at the
tapestry a little bit
it does seem that the destruction the
creation of the destruction or the yin
and yang of of life that it all works
only if
the the the main engine is towards
creativity but uh destruction also
makes way for new things
so that's the
this kind of struggle it seems like life
is a struggle between the different
forces that make up the individual human
they make up Society all this tensions
are necessary for growth for development
this kind of uh inner conflict and outer
conflict are necessary for growth it's
not just the
I mean in some sense it's from the logic
aspect you kind of want everything to be
perfect and and just for nobody to
suffer for everything to be perfect but
just like we talked about with trauma it
just seems like it's such a big giant
mess what is it Bukowski said uh fine
would you love and let it kill you uh
there's there's some aspect of uh the
negative aspect of passion and pursuit
and Obsession and the the the the the
turmoil of the pursuit of uh of
Happiness of the creative Pursuits and
all of that I mean I mean that's part of
life as well that's and I don't know
what to do with that
um from an individual perspective in
terms of figuring out how to how do you
live a good life how do you live a
healthy life because it does seem a bit
of hardship or sometimes a lot of
hardship
I can make a pretty interesting life I
think it brings us back to the to the
discussion that we're having sort of
before about like what does mean like
the challenges of trauma right and of
overcoming and I think here we gotta be
careful with the language right because
I I would then say let's take
destruction right and and separate it
into two things right like one is you
say destruction is like the the breaking
down the tearing down of something right
versus
a process that has malice in it right so
just like when we were talking about uh
trauma and and um no setbacks things to
overcome and we'd say okay if you say
Hey you have it harder than the next
person and you have more to overcome or
someone put a barrier in front of you
for you to overcome that there can be a
lot of growth in that including the
times when you don't know if you gosh
can I do this right can I get over it
right if you're saying like that's that
could be that's Challenge and and
something to overcome that's very
positive but we're saying but there's no
benefit of like throwing a racial slur
in there right you're saying because
that's all bad like that's not even the
princess I'm I'm angry about that I'm
going to overcome that it's like that
didn't need to be that didn't make
anything better if the person sees that
and says I'm gonna I'm gonna overcome
that it makes things less worse right
right is it but there's no there's no
good to something that's that's created
as destructive when we look at forest
fires like look controlled Burns he said
there's a forest burning down but that's
okay there's some this there's some
weakness destruction there there's a
tearing down there but it's in the
service of the next fire not running
through the community you know the town
that's on the other side of it that's
very different than a forest fire say
started by arson yeah right so you might
say they're both tearing down they're
tearing down of the forest but one is in
the service of goodness even though it's
hurting the animals and the plants it's
not all good right but but it's in the
service of something as opposed to
something else that's wantonly
destructive I think there's no good to
the racial slur there's no good to the
arson right that's destruction in a way
that's incorporating I think the malice
of envy you know something that's really
purely if there's a yin and yang that's
the destruct that's the destructive
that's the Badness end so racial slurs
is a surface wave of a deeper thing and
so I mean this is I mean the reason I
bring that up is like all right well
like you have these discussions of
censorship like what good does allowing
racial slurs in Public Communication do
right and it's like our communication
would surely be better if we don't say
bad things to each other it's like
it seems like the truth is our
communication will be better if the
amount of bad things is a small fraction
of communication that seems to be more
true because another aspect of human
nature with power the moment you start
censoring and removing bad words that
everyone agrees are bad words
then the people on the at the top
they're doing the sensory start getting
greedy they start it starts expanding
and this is the giant mess of human
civilization where we can't the the nice
piles you created are kind of
overlapping
it's a gray area yeah I agree with it no
I agree completely there's a good
control of language there are slippery
slopes there I think there's a there's a
very big problem there so I agree I I
think again split parsing out the
language I I'm not saying hey we
shouldn't have racial slurs as if like
let's stop saying the words I mean the
idea is the premise behind it right like
you know the the prejudices we could
eliminate the Prejudice behind it you
know I was struck I said I do not almost
nothing about medicine I get to medical
school and start with Anatomy right and
it's remarkable as you know to see where
as the bodies are being dissected that
like we're we're all humans like it does
it matter it doesn't matter any of these
things on the outside like and that's
true not just like in our bodies but but
in our minds the part of the person
that's not there right because now we're
trying to learn from the body and you
know it shows how
ridiculous it is if you think that we're
99 Point how many nines you know percent
all alike genetically and by the way
it's only like take another tenth off
and we're all orangutans right so but
somehow we we have to see these
differences between us right and where
does that come from and I think that I
believe that all comes from Envy in that
classical sense that if I don't feel
good enough I'm going to want someone to
feel better about and so there can be
visual things that uh that person looks
different right or you think about the
you know the I I spent some time in
Great Britain and when there's a lot of
conflict in between Northern Ireland and
Ireland right and you thought wow
there's not there's not even a look
difference right it's the same general
you know religious umbrella same
ethnicity right but but now there's some
religious difference and I thought it's
not me trying to be denigrating you know
around the Irish conflicts like that's
human of oh there's no actual difference
between us if I don't feel good about
myself I'm gonna find one right it's
that
that I believe could go away it's driven
by maybe the trauma of just being alive
in the world and things can happen to us
but we certainly promote in the human
created trauma people feeling not good
enough finding differences there's a
place for the Envy to attach and We're
Off to the Races of you know Wars I mean
we're talking about the second world war
and we think what have we learned since
then would take us a day to map out all
the wars since then right uh let alone
for goodness sakes everything that's
sailing it right now so we're not pretty
we're not good at learning from what
seemed to be some very Salient lessons